digamos que fx es igual a 1 sobre x y
queremos ver queremos pensar en lo que
el límite de fx es mientras x se
aproxima a 0 desde el lado positivo
entonces bueno para pensar en esto voy a
dibujar aquí una tabla ponemos a x x
luego pensamos en lo que fx va a hacer y
me voy a aproximar a 0 desde la
dirección positiva lo intentaremos con
el 0.1 entonces aquí pongo 0.1 luego con
0.01 0.01 después lo intentamos con
0.001 y después con 0.0001 porque no
entonces nota que cada uno de estos
números son mayores que 0 cierto se
aproximan al 0 desde el lado positivo
nos estamos acercando cada vez más a 0
entonces cuando x 0.1 f x simplemente va
a ser 1 sobre esto esto es un décimo así
que 1 sobre esto será 10 y luego uno
sobre 0.01 será entonces 100 1 sobre
0.001 será entonces 1000
y uno sobre 0.0001 va a ser diez mil
entonces diez mil así que como puedes
ver mientras x se aproxima cada vez más
a cero desde el lado positivo
fx crece muy muy muy rápido entonces lo
que decimos aquí es el límite de fx
mientras x se aproxima a cero desde el
lado positivo será igual a infinito
positivo o simplemente ponemos infinito
en esta cosa si ponemos 0.1 dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete dígitos después
del decimal entonces esto será uno sobre
uno con uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete a ver si lo hice bien aquí tenemos
los cuatro dígitos después de ver que ya
que tenemos cuatro ceros y aquí uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete dígitos
siete ceros muy bien ahora como puedes
ver mientras me acerco más y más a cero
desde el lado positivo la fx se hace más
y más y más y más grande por lo tanto
decimos que esto es igual a infinito
ahora pensemos en otro límite pensemos
en el límite mientras x se aproxima a 0
desde el lado negativo y bueno en este
caso podemos hacer cada uno de estos
valores negativos entonces si x es menos
0.1 esto será menos 10 menos 10 si esto
es negativo esto es negativo si esto es
negativo esto es negativo si esto es
negativo esto es negativo y si esto es
negativo esto es negativo lo que vemos
aquí es que si esto se hace más y más
grande un número grande en la dirección
negativa estamos pensando en una línea
de números que se va cada vez más y más
y más hacia la izquierda entonces
podemos decir que el límite de fx
mientras x se aproxima a 0 desde la
izquierda es igual a menos infinito eso
es muy interesante ya poco no claro que
si ahora pensemos en un límite mientras
x se aproxima ya sea al infinito
positivo o infinito negativo pensemos en
el límite de fx mientras x se aproxima a
infinito y una manera de poner la tabla
me es muy similar así que aquí pongo yo
fx si x es igual a 10 entonces fx es 1
sobre 10 10 1 sobre 10 si x es igual a
supongamos mil mil entonces fx es 1
sobre 1000 si x es un millón 1.000.000
entonces fx es uno sobre un millón ajá
como puedes ver mientras x crece más y
más y más cada vez más positivamente
está fx se acerca cada vez más a 0
puedes puedes decir que el límite de fx
mientras x se aproxima a infinito es
igual a cero ahora pensemos en el límite
límite de fx mientras x se aproxima a
menos infinito voy a tomar números que
son más y más y más cada vez más
negativos como aquí ahora sí que tengo
menos 10 acá tengo menos 1 sobre 10
menos 1000 entonces menos 1 sobre 1000 y
menos un millón entonces menos 1 sobre
un millón pero
aún vemos que nos aproximamos a cero
entonces esto una vez más será igual a
cero y bueno que implica todo esto
además de trabajar con límites yo aún no
te dado la definición formal de esto
pero ojalá te esté dando una intuición
mientras tomamos límites al infinito o
límites al ajax aquí y aquí x es menos
infinito ok límites al infinito o
límites al menos infinito o bueno cuando
el límite solamente es infinito o menos
infinito y bueno vamos a visualizar esto
vamos a graficar lo ya tenemos más o
menos la intuición así que gráfica
haremos la función fx es igual a 1 sobre
x entonces acá arriba y espacio lo voy a
poner acá con el color azul este es mi
eje de las x este es mi eje de las yes y
graphic amos a la función f x como vemos
mientras x es un número muy pequeño y es
igual a fx y será un número muy alto y
mientras más y más nos acercamos a cero
desde el lado positivo
fd x se aproxima a infinito entonces
sigue aproximando a infinito
nos aproximamos más a 0 mientras x se
aproxima más y más a 0 el valor de ye se
hace más y más grande entonces esta
parte que acabamos de ver ahorita más o
menos se ve así en la gráfica ahora
mientras nuestro valor de x se hace más
y más grande nuestro valor de fx se hace
más y más chico se mira algo así se
aproxima a 0
entonces similarmente si nos aproximamos
a x por el lado negativo qué va a pasar
como vimos vimos que fx se aproxima a
menos infinito así que mientras tenemos
a x cercanas a 0
nuestra f x se hace más y más y más
negativa y mientras nuestra x es más
negativa vemos que nuestra función se
aproxima cada vez más más y más a 0
la manera como yo lo dibujé vemos que
hay 2 assassins total cierto para la
gráfica amd fx igual a 1 sobre x tenemos
una cinta horizontal en que igual
aquí tenemos una cinta horizontal en
igual a 0 cuando x se aproxima a
infinito fx están se acerca a 0 pero
jamás llega a tocarlo y cuando se
aproxima a menos infinito fx está
acercándose a 0 pero igual jamás llega a
tocarlo es una asín tota y tenemos
también una sin tota vertical una asín
total vertical en x igual a 0 y por que
vemos esto esto lo vemos porque mientras
x se aproxima a 0 del lado positivo que
se aproxima a infinito y mientras x se
aproxima a 0 desde el lado negativo que
se aproxima a menos infinito así que
aquí cuando x es igual a cero si
observamos el límite mientras x se
aproxima a cero del lado positivo del
lado negativo vemos que se aproxima a
dos cosas distintas
entonces en definitiva tenemos una cinta
vertical en x igual a cero
el límite de fx mientras x se aproxima a
0 no está definido y por qué será eso
bueno cuando nos aproximamos a 0 del
lado positivo obtenemos algo diferente
que cuando nos aproximamos del lado
negativo